now panger and Liam also pointed out that Jonathan
drewan and Tomas tatara healthy stretches PES the
talk comes up big on Bren Shen Center Lane Drive
we saw that in the Buffalo Flyers game the boys
were talking about it there there's the pass
right on the tape and what a save that is why
the Russian goal tender moving across to his
right makes a save and covers up the rebound
it's a tough part of the business but now's the
time to send that message coic double team kaing
drops it off hero with the shot TI off the goal
post a far post of PR fov and it comes out through
Center and here's the pass to the right to Paro
and the shot glances off the stick up high and
off the bar and out there was a jump to my right
from the blues bench thinking that was in the net
and I can see why they would now Jacob bro little
to High play for Tucker his shot blocked by Ross
Colton out of the corner a tough angle Pros
vov had none of that Kevin Hayes Hayes trying
to get him cheating down low on the reverse
VH but no no the 6'5 goalie doesn't do that
go utilizes his feed to the outside Colorado off
and [Music] [Applause] running after the short
side play out of the Zone a little bang pass off
the boards Colton breaks in wide on Tucker and in
one quick motion gets it from the backand to the
forand and I am surprised how much velocity got
on this one and off the post and in a well placed
shot by Ross col that's just great speed coming
down the wing kale Mar risting one off the Stick
of bich off the Stick of Ryan Johansson in tight
Miko ran in MA looks over coverage Ranon in The
Sweet Spot scores M ranin makes no mistake it's
a power play goal 641 left in Period won two
nothing Colorado is when kale Mar walks the
line from a goalie's point of view nothing scarier
than that but bich hases a good job of staying in
the middle and blocking it but ranton who has had
great success against golender Jordan Bennington
that is now his 10th goal in 14 regular season
games and look at this shot there's traffic in
front oh two of them it's a double side formation
obviously the fans were not familiar with this
rule the height of the shoulder There It Is Well
that looks to me if you take the crossbar let's
take a look at that from from a straight line and
it has to be conclusive here we go after coach's
challenge video review it was determined that
there was no Miss game stoppage the calling R
has confirmed St Louis has assessed to bench
Min Fally for delay again Colton out of the
reach of Miles wood and Jake neighbors first
round pick through Center Ice backt tracking
Manson Colorado's in the chushin a shot snared
by Bingington save from the wing keep you're
on the right side and it's a good quick breakout
there by the Avalanche I'm sure the blues aren't
going to be happy about how quick that counter
happened and all of a sudden you've got a a real
good quality scoring chance but good andless you
tie marar McKinnon and R him up a knot somewhere
and hide him in a room Colorado has had the last
six scoring chances R goes deeper with it this
is exactly what C barui was talking about they're
getting chances like that one from Sammy bla that
was a tricky one there and here's the play the
leanan right here just pushes that ahead with some
good support by the blues and this one not sure
if it was labeled or not maybe this angle shows
us a little bit better yeah great save good Colton
defers out wood good backtracking by Hayes it's a
breakaway for br Jacob br's in stopped the rebound
kyou tried to capitalize and Prat off again here's
his chance on the previous sequence brought
on the Breakaway and the goenda pro pro what a
story lety now will draw back wait from McKinnon
boy linan went it hard let's keep her ey at number
62 hard into the post and he is in some pain
he's on the bench Thomas a shoty scores there's
the answer the St Louis Blues were looking for it
comes from Robert Thomas and they cut the lead in
half this what this starts I mean good breakout
positioning right lety finds the puck makes a
quick pass and going with speed that's what we've
seen from the St Louis Blues throt this second
period is more pressure you're passion options
on the entry oh what a play yeah momentum change
in that second period and the guys were talking
about it between periods and there was certainly a
change and certainly some things said in the Blues
locker room and now it's up the the Avalanche to
counter and grab back that mole that they had
in the first Far Side it goes kaan diagonally
for Fulk and now Thomas the waiting stages of the
power play Manson up and ready folk here it comes
off the outside of the post and skin out one shot
on goal for St Louis with that power play what a
shot there by Faulk lot of pucks on the outside
but man when you start firing the puck like that
everybody backs off and that was a Howitzer
through Center Ice lose see it picked off by
Kale Mar through the slot the trailer lacking and
denied by Bennington maard SS it through the top
of the crease Brandon missed that Devon Taves goes
deeper for M Ranson and out in front Le then he
scores AR Terry linan right on the doorstep 1819
left 3 to one Colorado stick side it comes down
the other way and that was the one that I thought
man how did Bron miss it it just went beyond his
blade but the big Power Forward stays with it puts
it on the sharp angle Mar might have fanned on it
but nonetheless it goes right to linan who Taps
that one in past the stick side there's a look at
the AT&T 5G net cam and Le and good positioning in
front all alone for a little too long he has been
a clutch player throughout his career Artu linan
two goal cushion again for Colorado miles wood
denied by Bennington on the short side side of the
goal tender and you see once again going Beyond
Tucker and Tucker's not in the position to cut
him off we talked about that on the first goal of
the game and it was Tucker that got beat by Colton
that's always good too as they start the mom trip
tonight which goes to Vegas tomorrow for a game
on Saturday kers McKinnon delays bym scores Bowen
myam it's a little pass from
Nathan McKinnon 4 to one
Avalanche look at the battle the strong work by
McKinnon even though paro's there Shen's there the
puck Pursuit then retreat Lees it has a great
passing or shot option but sees Byam sneaking
down you know Byrum's got that offensive mind to
get in the space just a simple little pass across
slow pass so Byron can bury that what a beautiful
play well Le did a great job in the corner he was
the one that took out basically this is ranan
now McKinnon ranin out in front bton comes up
huge what a stop on a beautiful play bronin wins
the battle but turns it over to Robert Thomas who
lugs it out short-handed with bich Thomas is there
shielded by Bros fov and it goes out of play got a
piece of that didn't he he did he beat him high
in the second period to the glove side but this
is a terrific give go on a two on three and it
goes off The Far Side rolls around for Jordan Kyu
of St Louis broken up by Byrum and it comes out
to Center Ice 240 left here in Denver empty net
for Samuel Gerard up the [Applause] crossbar
weak side of the ice and I I was looking at
Justin faul great in front of me and it is kind
of looking up and thinking no that's a goal right
there but a break right off the bar and out of
play this will be win number 900 here in Denver
at home win number 600 but win number one as
a Colorado avalan for the Young goenda proov